welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Anthony Mason and Tony
to copal critics say that a
controversial startup poses a new and
profound threat to everyone's privacy
with its facial recognition technology
so we spoke to the CEO and his first
Network TV interview Clearview AI
co-founder and co-executive his name is
wonton tot showed our aerobar net just
how easy it is to find images of him the
cutting-edge software can identify
people by comparing their pictures to
billions of images Clearview has scraped
from the social media and the Internet
Errol Barnett is here in the studio with
more on this good morning I'm very
fascinated here when you got to say
listen up to this good morning everyone
clear view ai CEO says he wants you to
trust him he's trying to gain the
public's trust here the 31 year old says
his company's facial recognition
technology is only available to law
enforcement and is to be used to
identify potential criminals but there
are serious questions about whether his
software is too invasive right now we
have you know billions and billions of
images from millions of different
websites all across the open Internet
this is what Clearview a eyes database
would look like to law enforcement says
found a wanton tat if for example they
were searching for me I mean I got to
say it's slightly unnerving seeing
someone able to scroll through so many
images of my face but you have to
remember that this is only used for
investigations after the fact this is
not a 24/7 surveillance system
Tom tat says his artificial intelligence
program can identify someone from an
image in seconds it matches faces of
unknown people to their online photos
and the sights the images originally
came from the results he says on 99.6%
accurate would you like to have it right
sure when we tried out the company's
phone app even covering half my face it
still worked on the first try Don Todd
says Clear View has 3 billion images in
its database sourced from millions of
websites and social media platforms in a
method known as scraping wired
editor-in-chief Nick Thompson says
facial recognition raises sobering moral
and ethical question
in order to build it you have to scrape
a lot of public information in ways that
may be legal but that certainly goes
against the Terms of Service of
companies like Facebook and Twitter
secondly this is really creepy and the
big companies who have the data already
haven't wanted to do it YouTube Facebook
venmo and Twitter told CBS News scraping
is against their policies last night
Google and YouTube sent Clearview a
cease and desist letter and this comes
weeks after Twitter did the same demand
and Clear View stops scraping pictures
from their platform and delete any data
taken are you aiming to comply with
Twitter our legal counsel has reached
out to them and are handling it
accordingly but there is also a First
Amendment right to public information so
the way we have built our system is to
only take publicly available information
and index it that way and you believe
you have a First Amendment right
completely access what yes Clearview
says more than 600 law enforcement
agencies across the country use this
software but wouldn't say how many are
free trial subscriptions New Jersey
Attorney General Kabir Grewal recently
ordered state law enforcement agencies
to temporarily stop using this
technology until they learn more what
are your concerns with this technology
I'm not categorically opposed to facial
recognition technology
I think used properly it can help us
solve criminal cases more quickly it can
help us apprehend child abusers domestic
terrorists but what I am opposed to is
the wide scale collection of biometric
information and the use of it without
proper safeguards by law enforcement but
Tom tat argues Clearview AI is
essentially a search engine for faces
Google can pull in information from all
different web sites so if it's public
you know and it's out there and it could
be inside Google search engine you can
be inside ours as well in a statement to
CBS News Google calls that comparison
inaccurate writing quote we give
webmasters control over what information
from their site is included in our
search results including the option to
opt out
this platform is very powerful but it
relies on transparency the people to
trust and believe it yeah and there just
isn't much of that available right now
well that's why I'm here on TV
explaining all these things and that's
why we meet with a lot of the people in
government tanta tells CBS News the
technology won't be made available to
the general public as long as he's
running clear view but Thompson says it
may not be so simple clear view says you
may be worried about our technology but
it's just used by police departments to
catch terrorists and keep you safe but
if we know anything from the history of
technology and the history of Silicon
Valley it's that the initial intended
use is not the only use now tanta told
us subscription prices vary but to give
you a rough idea one of the largest
police departments in the country pays
roughly fifty thousand dollars for a
two-year contract now clear view keeps
all images even if they are deleted from
the website at where they are sourced
and the New York Times which really
broke this story open the reporter
cashmere Hill last month reports that
the company is working on a tool that
would let people request to have those
images taken down yeah request doesn't
mean they comply a big question here is
it's not against the law as Nick
Thompson points out and in in the
absence of some sort of national federal
regulation these companies are left to
do whatever they want yes precisely and
the other concern is that what if police
officers take images out of context what
if they see you at a rally or a
demonstration and those images become
part of a profile that they build tom
tat says look if it's public information
and it's already out there we are just
sourcing it and matching he has an
argument but I'm with Nick Thompson it's
really creepy it's creepy people are
divided on whether or not this is a
benefit to society or whether it really
crosses a line you know what was like
seeing all those pictures of you err
well you know even when you covered your
mouth that they could that's what struck
me at the power of this technology and
for me look I've been a reporter my
entire adult life I expected to see some
of those images but some of them I had
never seen before my fraternity put me
in some type of profile I had never seen
that someone put a doll next to a
television I had never seen and so it is
powerful technology initial intentions
are not n results they change
thank you I appreciate it good thing
they didn't uncover anything well system
somewhere else not with arrow burn head